foreign
[Music]
I want to play a game
to kill Adam you have until six on the
clock to do it
the newspaper started calling him the
jigsaw Killer looks like our friend
jigsaw likes to book himself front row
seats to his own sick little games
you could be the one who put me in this
room
I'm gonna have to work together if we
want to get out of here
there's a man in my room
what are you doing
great
[Music]
to overcome something you have to
understand what a perfect engine it is
he doesn't want us to cut through a
chains he wants us to cut through our
feet
thick bastard
yes I'm sick officer
there's a way out of here
we're out of time
ah
before die
make your choice
nobody knows we all just woke up here
like you
everything you need to know is on this
greetings and welcome I trust that you
are all wondering where you are
what is this
who the hell is jigsaw he's a serial
killer he's testing us he wants us to
survive this how do you know all this
because I've played before
I want to play a game the rules are
simple listen to me it's ticking
unfortunately you only have two hours to
live
saving the after school special it's
called being a father
where is he oh yes
those who don't appreciate life do not
deserve life
I selected you for the honor of carrying
on my life's work
it's time to start our game
Justice
I sure did
I died make your choice
thank you
so I just not could trigger it I should
know I built it
[Applause]
[Music]
you think it's over just because I'm
dead it's not over
hello Officer Rick you have witnessed to
our colleagues disappear
tonight I give you the opportunity to
save everyone
welcome to your rebirth
two officers are missing
I am just curious as to why take off the
mask put your hands in here the games
have just begun
it's being recruited
I am still among you
my work will continue
thank you
hello agent strong
if you're hearing this then you finally
found what you've been looking for
I was supposed to die in that trap we no
longer handling the case Peter on Whose
orders mine
what do you want from me
never thought you were capable of being
[Music]
[Applause]
have you learned enough to trust me
[Music]
the jigsaw killer may be dead but the
murders continue
I'm leaving you a box today
and his work is almost done
I ask you have you learned enough to
trust me my legacy will become yours
from now on I control all aspects of the
game
someone's there they're watching us
[Applause]
You are not alone in this game six ride
the carousel
it's a game
[Music]
since the beginning
you have watched others suffer
now it is your turn to play
game over
the last piece of the puzzle is you
[Music]
another game's simple
best ones are
your mercy
played by the rules
the identification on the victim
puzzle piece
it's not him
is this was on the body
the truth will set you free
[Music]
I'm chasing the dead man
[Applause]
live or die
[Music]
the blood under the fingernails of our
victims John Kramer the jigsaw killer
that's impossible
[Music]
no that's not creepy at all
[Applause]
[Music]
this package just came in
get everybody out of here
play me
[Music]
hello detector Banks do you know where
your officers are
jigsaw
[Music]
where I thought the jigsaw killer was
dead
he is
I think they're hours not days how could
I catch this guy if there's nobody on
the force
you can't do this alone
whoever did this as another motive
something personal
when was the last time you saw your
father
[Applause]
jigsaw copycat it's just gonna go
sideways fast
[Music]
all available units officer down that
was just an aversion to get us out of
the precinct
I need everyone on this cake
it could be anywhere it could be anyone
we're gonna tear this city apart
[Applause]
happens
[Music]
when was the last time
you saw your father
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
thank you
in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
life
John Kramer
according to these scans the tumor was
never removed how much gun do I have
months at best I still have a lot of
work that needs to be done
[Music]
hello everyone it's time to play a game
you all pretended to kill me the one I
have planned for each of you is very
real
[Music]
friends
only thing I have not provided is your
anesthetic but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
yeah I agree
I have all the men to cheat you picked
John Kramer please don't hesitate place
a big enough piece of your cerebral
tissue into the glass enzyme tank this
will save your life
it's not retribution it's a Reawakening
[Music]
little dog the choice is yours